لهم ما
يشاءون عند
ربهم ذلك
جزاء
المحسنين ليكفر الله عنهم اسوا الذي عملوا
ويجزيهم
اجرهم
ويجزيهم اجرهم باحسن الذي كانوا
يعملون اليس الله بكاف
عبده
ويخوفونك بالذين من
دونه ومن يضلل الله فما له من
هاد ومن يهدي الله فما له من مضل اليس
الله
بعزيز ذ
انتقام ولئن
سالتهم من خلق السماوات والارض
ليقولن
الله قل
افرايتم ما تدعون من دون الله ان ارادني
الله
بضر ان ارادني الله بضر هل هن كاشفات ضره
او ارادني برحمه هل
هن ممسكات
رحمته قل حسبي
الله عليه يتوكل
المتوكلون قل يا قوم اعملوا على مكانتكم
اني
عامل فسوف تعلمون من ياتيه عذاب
يخزيه ويحل عليه
عذاب
مقيم الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
انا
انزلنا عليك الكتاب
للناس
بالحق فمن اهتدى فلنفسه ومن ضل فانما يضل
عليها وما انت عليهم
بوكيل الله يتوفى الان
حين
موتها والتي لم تمت في
منامها فيمسك اللتي قضى عليها الموت ويرسل
الاخرى الى اجل
مسى
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يتفكرون ام اتخذوا من دون الله شفعاء
قل اولو كانوا لا يملكون شيئا ولا
يعقلون قل لله الشفاعه
جميعا له ملك السماوات والارض
ثم اليه
ترجعون واذا ذكر الله وحده اشمازت قلوب
الذين لا يؤ
بالاخره واذا ذكر الذين من دونه اذا هم
يستبشرون قل
اللهم فاطر السماوات والارض عالم الغيب
والشهاده انت تحكم بين عبادك فيما كانوا
فيه يخت
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلامكه so we the theo came last
december ja
الله
اهد
ال الله
واشهد مح ع ع
وسوله i be i there is there
is of wor
‏wory of worship of worship except allah
and i be
i mamm صل الله صل الله عليه عل
وسمم servant serv and messenger
تكبير تكبير تكبير
[Silence]
‏you
كش ما شاء الله
[Silence]
‏v
‏t
[Silence]
‏var
ا
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل
استو سوا الصفد
[Silence]
الخلل
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولو ان للذين ظلموا ما في الارض
جميعا ومثله معه لافتدوا به لافتدوا به من
سوء العذاب يوم القيامه وبد لهم من الله
ما لم يكونوا
يحتسبون وبد لهم سيئات ما كسبوا وحاق بهم
ما كانوا به
يستهزئون فاذا مس
الانسان ضر دعانا ثم اذا خولناه نعمه منا
قال انما اوتيته على علم بل هي فتنه ولكن
اكثرهم لا
يعلمون قد قالها الذين من قبلهم فما اغنى
عنهم ما كانوا
يكسبون فاصابهم سيئات ما كسبوا والذين
ظلموا من
هؤلاء سيصيبهم سيئات ما كسبوا وما هم
بمعجزين اولم يعلموا ان الله يبسط الرزق
لمن
يشاء
ويقدر ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يؤمنون قل يا عبادي الذين اسرفوا على
انفسهم لا
تقنطوا لا تقنطوا من رحمه الله ان الله
يغفر الذنوب جميعا
انه هو الغفور رحيم وانيبوا الى ربكم
واسلموا له من قبل ان ياتيكم
العذاب من قبل ان ياتيكم العذاب ثم لا
تنصرون واتبعوا احسن ما انزل اليكم من
ربكم من قبل ان ياتيكم العذاب بغته وانتم
لا
تشعرون ان تقول نفسي يا حسره على ما فرضت
في جنب
الله وان كنت لمن
الساخرين او تقول لو ان الله هداني لكنت
من المتقين او تقول حين ترى العذاب لو ان
لي كره لو ان لي
كره فاكون من المحسنين
بل قد
جاءتك اياتي فكذبت بها واستكبرت وكنت من
الكافرين ويوم القيامه ترى الذين كذبوا
على الله
وجوههم
مسوده اليس في
جهنم مثوى
للمتكبرين وينجي الله الذين اتقوا
بمفازتهم لا يمسهم
السوء لا يمسهم
السوء ولا هم
يحزنون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن ال
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين الله خالق كل شيء وهو على كل شيء
وكيل له مقاليد السماوات والارض والذين
كفروا بايات الله
اولئك هم
الخاسرون قل افغير الله
تامروني اعبد ايها
الجاهلون ولقد اوحي اليك والى الذين من
قبلك لئن اشركت ليحبطن
عملك
ليحبطن عملك
ولتكونن من
الخاسرين بل الله فاعبد وكن من
الشاكرين وما قدر الله حق قدره والارض
جميعا قبضته يوم
القيامه والسماوات
مطويات
بيمينه سبحانه وتعالى عما
يشركون ونفخ في الصور فصعق من في السماوات
ومن في الارض الا من شاء الله ثم نفخ فيه
اخرى فاذا هم قيام ينظرون
واشرقت الارض بنور ربها ووضع
الكتاب
وجيء
بالنبيين
والشهداء وقضي بينهم
بالحق وقضي بينهم بالحق وهم لا
يظلمون ووفيت كل نفس ما عملت وهو اعلم بما
يفعلون
وسيق الذين كفروا الى جهنم
زمرا حتى اذا
جاؤوها فتحت ابوابها وقال لهم
خزنتها وقال لهم خزنتها الم ياتكم رسل
منكم يتلون عليكم ايات ربكم
وينذرونكم وين كم
لقاء يومكم
هذا قالوا بلى ولكن حقت كلمه العذاب على
الكافرين قيل ادخلوا ابواب جهنم خالدين
فيها فبئس مثوى
المتكبرين وسيق الذين اتقوا ربهم الى
الجنه
زمرا حت حتى اذا
جاؤوها وفتحت ابوابها وقال لهم
خزنتها وقال لهم خزنتها سلام
عليكم سلام عليكم طبتم فادخلوها
خالدين وقالوا الحمد لله الذي صدقنا وعده
واورثنا الارض واورثنا الارض تبوا من
الجنه حيث
نشاء فنعم اجر
العاملين وترى
الملائكه
حافين من حول العرش
يسبحون يسبحون بحمد ربهم وقضي بينهم
بالحق وقيل الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
الله اكبر سبحانك
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
حاميم تنزيل الكتاب من الله العزيز العليم
غافر الذنب وقابل التوب شديد
العقاب ذي الطول ذ الطول لا اله الا هو
اليه المصير ما يجادل في ايات الله الا
الذين
كفروا فلا يغررك تقلبهم في
البلاد كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح والاحزاب من
بعدهم وهمت كل امه برسولهم
لياخذه وجادلوا بالباطل ليدحضوا به الحق
فاخذتهم فاخذتهم فكيف كان
عقاب وكذلك حق وكذلك حق حقت كلمه ربك على
الذين كفروا
انهم
انهم اصحاب
النار الذين يحملون العرش ومن حوله يسبحون
بحمد
ربهم يسبحون بحمد ربهم ويؤمنون به
ويستغفرون للذين امنوا
ربنا ربنا وسع كل شيء
رحمه
وعلما فاغفر للذين تابوا واتبعوا سبيلك
وقهم عذاب
الجحيم ربنا وادخلهم جنات عدن التي وعدتهم
ومن صلح من
ابائهم وازواجهم
وذرياتهم انك
انت العزيز الحكيم وقهم
السيئات ومن تق السيئات يومئذ فقد رحمته
وذلك هو الفوز العظيم ان الذين كفروا
ينادون لمقت الله اكبر من مقتكم
انفسكم اذ تدعون الى الايمان فتكفرون
قالوا ربنا امتنا اثنتين واحييتنا اثنتين
فاعترفنا
بذنوبنا فهل الى خروج من سبيل ذلكم
بانه اذا دعي الله وحده كفرتم وان يشرك به
تؤمنوا فالحكم لله العلي
الكبير هو الذي يريكم اياته وينزل لكم من
السماء رزقا وما يتذكر الا من ينيب فادعوا
الله مخلصين له الدين ولو كره
الكافرون رفيع الدرجات ذو العرش يلقي
الروح من امره على من يشاء من عباده لينذر
يوم
التلاق يومهم بارزون لا يخفى على الله
منهم
شيءء لمن الملك
اليوم لمن الملك
اليوم لله الواحد
القهار اليوم تجزى كل نفس بما كسبت لا
اليوم ان الله سريع
الحساب
وانذرهم يوم الازفه اذ القلوب لدى الحناجر
كاظمين ما للظالمين من حميم ولا شفيع
يطاع يعلم
خائنه الاعين وما تخفي الصدور
والله يقضي بالحق والذين يدعون من دونه لا
يقضون
بشيء ان الله هو السميع
البصير الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكب الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين اولم يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف
كان عاقبه الذين كانوا من قبلهم كانوا هم
اشد منهم قوه واث ارا في الارض فاخذهم
الله
بذنوبهم وما كان لهم من الله من
واق ذلك
بانهم كانت تاتيهم رسلهم بالبينات
فكفروا فكفروا فاخذهم
الله ان الله قوي شديد
العقاب ولقد ارسلنا موسى باياتنا وسلطان
مبين الى فرعون وهامان وقارون فقالوا ساحر
كذاب فلما
جاءهم بالحق من
عندنا قالوا اقتلوا
ابناء الذين امنوا معه واستحيوا نساء
هم وما كيد الكافرين الا في
ضلال وقال فرعون وما كيد الكافرين الا في
ضلال وقال فرعون ذروني اقتل موسى وليدع
ربه اني اخاف ان يبدل دينكم او ان يظهر في
الارض
الفساد وقال موسى اني عذت بربي
وربكم من كل
متكبر من كل متكبر لا يؤمن بيوم
الحساب وقال رجل مؤمن من ال فرعون يكتم
ايمانه اتقتلون رجلا ان يقول ربي الله
وقد
جاءكم
بالبينات من
ربكم وان يك
كاذبا فعليه كذبه وان يك صادقا يصبكم بعض
الذي
يعدكم ان الله لا يهدي من هو مسرف
كذاب يا قوم لكم الملك اليوم ظاهرين في
الارض فمن
ينصرنا من باس الله ان
جاءنا قال فرعون ما اريكم الا ما ارى وما
اهديكم الا سبيل
الرشاد وقال الذي امن يا قوم اني اخاف
عليكم مث مثل يوم
الاحزاب مثل داب قوم نوح وعاد وثمود
والذين من
بعدهم وما الله يريد ظلما
للعباد ويا قوم
اني اخاف عليكم يوم
التناد يوم تولون مدبرين ما لكم من الله
من
عاصم ومن يضلل الله فما له من
هاد ولقد
جاءكم يوسف من قبل بالبينات فما زلتم فما
زلتم في شك مما جاءكم به حتى اذا هلك قلتم
لن يبعث الله من بعده ر رسولا كذلك يضل
الله من هو مسرف
مرتاب الذين يجادلون في ايات الله بغير
سلطان الذين يجادلون في ايات الله بغير
سلطان اتاهم كبر مقتا عند الله كبر مقتا
عند الله الله وعند الذين
امنوا كذلك يطبع الله على كل قلب وعلى كل
قلب
متكبر
جبار وقال فرعون يا هامان ابن لي صرحا
لعلي ابلغ
الاسباب اسباب السماوات فاطلع الى اله
موسى وان اني لا اظنه
كاذبا وكذلك زين لفرعون لفرعون سوء
عمله وصد عن
السبيل وما كيد فرعون الا في
تباب وقال الذي امن يا قوم اتبعوني اهدكم
سبيل
الرشاد يا قوم ان انما هذه الحياه الدنيا
متاع وان الاخره هي دار
القرار من عمل
سيئه فلا يجزى الا
مثلها ومن عمل صالحا من ذكر او انثى وهو
مؤمن فاولئك
يدخلون
الجنه
فاولئك
يدخلون
الجنه يرزقون فيها بغير
حساب الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ه
ك اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اقم الصلاه لدلوك الشمس الى غسق
الليل وقران
الفجر ان قران الفجر كان
مجهودا ومن الليل فتهجد به نافله لك
عسى ان يبعثك ربك مقا
صدق الله
العظي رب صدر
ويان ق اللهم على سدنا محمد القوب ودعاه
ونور الابصار وه وعافيه الابدان وشفاه
اللهم ارنا الح
حق وارنا ال ورقنا اجتنابه الل ربنا لما
تح
السلام and
lally on this
equally
equally this as all
23 so
i take time
[Silence]
الصلا الشد
‏days and would have a the and slowly
slowly go
down and
[Silence]
‏est make make make
‏other dark body why because
blackness
from into
سبحان الله الله سبحانه
وتالى
الص انصلا ونق
وحمات لله رب
[Silence]
العالمين صل عليه
محصلش سبحان
الله حث
حجر
عش سبحان الله
[Silence]
‏was light per my
eyes i think
ies think one the first
سبحان
اللهب ا
[Silence]
‏as
asting i for first
and all us that have we la the
foundations for the remaining 365 days
of our life have we
[Arabic recitation]
‏we are wake up we are wake
up at the same time the question then
becomes can we keep this momentum and so
ان ان ان i ask allah سانه waal for mercy
especially on this night and i i pray
for all of my beautiful beloved brothers
and my esteemed brothers and sisters and
my esteemed uncl
ands j and and everyone may allah accept
from us
ربنا ربنا د ربنا وقي يا
الله وان عغفر وانا عواد بالذنب اقول قول
هذا واستغفر الله لي وللام
[Silence]
استووا اعتدلوا ساووا الصفوف
استووا الله
اكبر بسم الله
ال الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ويا قوم مالي ادعوكم الى الن
وتدعونني الى
النار تدعونني لاكفر بالله واشرك به ما
ليس لي به علم وانا ادعوكم الى العزيز
الغفار لا جرم ان ما تدعون اليه ليس له
دعوه في الدنيا ولا في
الاخره وان مردنا الى الله
وان المسرفين همهم اصحاب
النار فستذكرون ما اقول لكم وافوض امري
الى الله ان الله بصير
بالعباد فوقاه الله سيئات ما مكروا وحاق
بال فرعون سوء
العذاب النار يعرضون عليها غدوا وعشيا
ويوم تقوم الساعه ادخلوا ال فرعون اشد
العذاب واذ
يتحاجون في النار فيقول
الضعفاء للذين استكبروا انا كنا لكم
تبعا انا كنا لكم تبعا فهل انتم مغنون عنا
نصيبا من
النار قال الذين استكبروا انا كل فيها ان
الله قد حكم بين
العباد وقال الذين في النار لخزنه جهنم
ادعوا ربكم يخفف عنا يوما من
العذاب قالوا اولم تك تاتيكم رسلكم
بالبينات قالوا بلى قالوا فادعوا وما دعاء
الكافرين الا في
ضلال انا
لننصر رسلنا والذين امنوا في الحياه
الدنيا ويوم يقوم
الاشهاد يوم لا ينفع الظالمين معذرتهم
ولهم اللعنه ولهم سوء
الدار ولقد اتينا موسى الهدى واورثنا بني
اسرائيل
الكتاب هدى وذكرى لاولي
الالباب فاصبر ان وعد الله حق واستغفر
لذنبك وسبح بحمد ربك بالعشي والابكار
ان الذين يجادلون في ايات الله بغير سلطان
اتاهم ان في صدورهم الا كبر ما هم
ببالغيه فاستعذ بالله انه هو السميع
البصير لخلق السماوات والارض اكبر من خلق
الناس ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون وما يستوي الاعمى والبصير والذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات ولا
المسيء قليلا ما
تتذكرون ان الساعه لاتيه لا ريب فيها ولكن
اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون وقال ربكم ادعوني استجب لكم ان
الذين يستكبرون عن عبادتي سيدخلون ج جهنم
داخرين الله الذي جعل لكم الليل لتسكنوا
فيه والنهار مبصرا ان الله لذو فضل على
الناس ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يشكرون ذلكم الله ربكم ذلكم الله ربكم
خالق كل شيء لا اله الا هو انا
تؤفكون كذلك يؤفك الذين كانوا بايات الله
يجحدون الله الذي جعل لكم الارض قرارا
والسماء
بناء وصوركم فاحسن صوركم ورزقكم من
الطيبات ذلكم الله ربكم ذلكم الله ربكم
فتبارك الله رب
العالمين هو الحي لا اله الا هو فادعوه
مخلصين له
الدين الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط والذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين هو الحي لا اله الا و فادعوه مخلصين
له الدين الحمد لله رب
العالمين قل اني نهيت ان اعبد الذين تدعون
من دون الله لما
جاءني البينات من ربي وامرت لان اكون من
المسلمين وامرت ان اكون من
المسلمين هو الذي خلقكم من تراب
ثم وامرت بان اسلم لرب
العالمين هو الذي خلقكم من تراب ثم من
نطفه ثم من علقه ثم يخرجكم طفلا ثم
لتبلغوا اشدكم ثم لتكونوا
شيوخا ومنكم من يتوفى من قبل ولتبلغوا
اجلا مسما ولعلكم تعقل
هو الذي يحيي
ويميت فاذا قضى امرا
فانما يقول له كن
فيكون الم تر الى الذين يجادلون في ايات
الله انا
يصرفون الذين كذبوا بالكتاب وبما ارسلنا
به رسلنا فسوف
يعلمون اذ الاغلال في اعنا قهم والسلاسل
يسحبون في الحميم ثم في النار
يسجرون ثم قيل لهم اينما كنتم
تشركون من دون
الله قالوا ضلوا عنا بل لم نكن ندعو من
قبل شيئا كذلك يضل الله
الكافرين ذلكم بما كنتم تفرحون في الارض
بغير الحق وبما كنتم
تمرحون ادخلوا ابواب جهنم خالدين فيها
فبئس مثوى
المتكبرين فاصبر ان وعد الله حق فاما
نرينك بعض الذين عدهم او نتوفينك
فالينا يرجعون
ولقد ارسلنا رسلا من قبلك منهم من قصصنا
عليك ومنهم من لم نقصص عليك وما كان لرسول
ان ياتي بايه الا باذن
الله فاذا جاء امر الله قضي بالحق وخسر
هنالك
المبطلون هو الذي جعل لكم الانعا لتركبوا
منها ومنها
تاكلون الله الذي جعل لكم الانعام لتركبوا
تاكلون ولكم فيها منافع ولتبلغوا عليها
حاجه في
صدوركم وعليها وعلى الفلك
تحملون ويريكم اياته فاي ايات الله
تنكرون افلم يسيروا في الارض
فينظروا كيف كان عاقبه الذين من
قبلهم كانوا اكثر منهم واشد قوه
واثار في الارض فما اغنى عنهم ما كانوا
يكسبون فلما
جاءتهم رسلهم بالبينات فرحوا ما عندهم من
العلم وحاق بهم وحاق بهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون فلما راوا باسنا قالوا امنا
بالله وكفرنا بما كنا به
مشركين فلما راوا باسنا قالوا امنا بالله
وحده وكفرنا بما كنا به
مشركين فلم يك ينفعهم ايمانهم لما راوا
باسنا سنه الله التي قد خلت في عباده وخسر
هنالك
الكافرون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الددين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
حمم تنزيل من الرحمن الرحيم كتاب فصلت
اياته قرانا عربيا لقوم يعلمون بشير
ونذيرا فاعرض اكثرهم فهم لا يسمعون وقالوا
قلوبنا في
اكنه مما تدعونا اليه وفي اذاننا وقر ومن
بيننا وبينك
حجاب فاعمل اننا
عاملون قل انما انا بشر مثلكم يوحى الي
انما الهكم الى
واحد فاستقيموا اليه
واستغفروه وويل
للمشركين الذين لا يؤتون الزكاه وهم
بالاخره هم
كافرون ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لهم اجر غير
ممنون قل
اكم لتكفرون بالذي خلق الارض في يومين
وتجعلون له ان
دادا ذلك رب
العالمين وجعل فيها رواسي من فوقها وبارك
فيها وقدر فيها
اقواتها وقدر فيها اقواتها في اربعه ايام
سواء
للسائلين ثم استوى الى السماء وهي دخان
فقال لها للارض ائتيا طوعا او كرها قالت
اتينا
طائعين فقضاهن سبع سماوات في يومين واوحى
في كل سماء امرها وزينا السماء الدنيا
بمصابيح وحفظا ذلك تقدير العزيز
العليم فان اعرضوا فقل انذرتكم صاعقه مثل
صاعقه عاد
وثمود اذ جاءتهم الرسل من بين ايديهم ومن
خلفهم الا تعبدوا الا الله قالوا لو شاء
ربنا لانزل
ملائكه فانا بما ارسلتم به
كافرون فاما عاد فاستكبروا
في الارض بغير الحق وقالوا من اشد منا قوه
اولم يروا ان الله الذي خلقهم هو اشد منهم
قوه وان وكانوا باياتنا
يجحدون فارسلنا عليهم ريحا صرصرا في ايام
نحسات
لنذيقهم لنذيقهم عذاب الخزي في الح
الدنيا ولعذاب الاخره اخزى وهم لا
ينصرون واما ثمود فهديناهم فاستحبوا الماى
على الهدى فاخذتهم صاعقه العذاب الهون بما
كانوا
يكسبون ونجينا الذين امنوا وكانوا
يتقون ويوم يحشر
اعداء الله الى النار فهم
يوزعون حتى اذا ما
جاؤوها شهد عليهم سمعهم وابصارهم وجلودهم
بما كانوا
يعملون وقالوا لجلودهم لم شهدتم علينا
قالوا انطقنا الله الذي
انطق كل شيء وهو خلقكم اول مره واليه
ترجعون وما كنتم تستترون ان يشهد عليكم
سمعكم ولا ابصاركم ولا
جلودكم ولكن ظننتم ان الله لا يعلم كثيرا
مما
تعملون وذلكم ظنكم الذي ظننتم بربكم
ارداكم فاصبحتم من
الخاسرين فان يصبروا فالنار مثوا لهم وان
يستعتبوا فما هم من
المعتبين وقيضنا لهم
قرناء
فزي وقيضنا لهم قرناء فزينوا لهم ما بين
ايديهم وما خلفهم وحق عليه م القول في امم
قد خلت من قبلهم من الجن والانس انهم
كانوا
خاسرين وقال الذين كفروا لا تسمعوا لهذا
القران والغوا فيه لعلكم
تغلبون فلنذيقن
الذين كفروا عذابا شديدا
ولنجزينهم اسوا الذي كانوا يعملون
ذلك
جزاء
اعداء الله
النار لهم فيها دار الخلد
جزاء بما كانوا باياتنا
يجحدون وقال الذين كفروا ربنا ارنا الذين
اضلانا من الجن والانس نجعلهما تحت
اقدامنا نجعلهما تحت اق امنا ليكونا من
الاسفلين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين
ان الذين قالوا ربنا الله ثم استقاموا
تتنزل عليهم
الملائكه تتنزل عليهم
الملائكه الا تخافوا ولا تحز
وابشروا بالجنه التي كنتم
توعدون نحن
اولياؤكم في الحياه الدنيا وفي
الاخره ولكم فيها ما تشتهي انفسكم ولكم
فيها ما
تدعون نزلا من غفور
رحيم ومن احسن قولا ممن دعا الى الله وعمل
صالحا وقال انني من
المسلمين ولا تستوي الحسنه ولا
السيئه ادفع بالتي هي احسن فاذا الذي بينك
وبينه عداوه كانه ولي
حميم وما يلقاها الا الذين صبروا وما
يلقاها الا ذو حظ
عظيم واما
ينزغنك من الشيطان نزغ فاستعذ
بالله انه هو السميع
العليم ومن اياته الليل والنهار والشمس
والقمر لا تسجدوا للشمس ولا للقمر واسجدوا
لله الذي خلقهن ان كنتم اياه
تعبدون فان استكبروا فالذين عند ربك
يسبحون الليل
والنهار يسبحون بالليل والنهار
وهم فان استكبروا فالذين عند ربك يسبحون
له بالليل والنهار وهم لا
يسامون الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر ومن اياته انك ترى الارض خاشعه فاذا
انزلنا عليها الماء اهتزت
وربت ان الذي احياها لمحيي الموتى انه على
كل شيء
قدير ان الذين يلحدون في اياتنا لا يخفون
علينا افمن يلقى في النار خير ام من ياتي
امنا يوم
القيامه اعملوا ما شئتم انه بما تعملون
بصير
ان الذين كفروا بالذكر لما
جاءهم وانه لكتاب
عزيز لا ياتيه الباطل من بين يديه ولا من
خلفه تنزيل من حكيم
حميد ما يقال لك الا ما قد قيل للرسل من
قبلك ان ربك لذو مغفره وذو عقاب
اليم ولو جعلناه قرانا اعجميا لقالوا لولا
فصلت اياته اعجمي
وعربي قل هو للذين امنوا هدى
وشفاء والذين لا يؤمنون في اذانهم وقر وهو
عليهم عى اولئك ينادون من مكان
عيد ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب فاختلف فيه
ولولا كلمه سبقت من ربك لقضي
بينهم وانهم لفي شك منه
مريب من عمل
صالحا فلنفسه ومن اساء
فعليها وما ربك بظلام للعبيد
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
السلام عليكم و ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏st
sk est
‏please in the line in fr of you first
please people left take
spots
seconds in mle and
[Silence]
‏st
خ الله
سبحان الله اكبر
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي ق ف هدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء ان
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك
لليسرى ف ذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من
يغشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر ه